on Thursday 30th of March 2023 my
vehicle be addictive guilty which has
confirmed our belief that Kashmir made
as our beautiful Olivia
Olivia was just beautiful with their
long brown hair
and big brown eyes she was such a social
butterfly she was particularly good with
the younger children
I'm a such a caring little girl
live was the life of Our Lives a sassy
chatty Gale who never ran out of energy
she was a character she was my baby and
she has amazing qualities and knew what
she wanted in life
everyone adored here she was the baby
off of our family and my little love my
shadow
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with us all I promise for
their future so cruelly taken away
we can now draw a line onto seven months
of agonizing torments that we had to
we have had to endure at the hands of
Cashman
justice has prevailed and I cannot begin
to express our relief
I would like to extend our sincere
gratitude and thanks to Mr McLaughlin
and Mr Rising
the CPS all the investigation team and
police officers involved in working
tires tirelessly to get this to court
my thanks go to the witnesses you
bravely assisted the prosecution case
identified the usual stance of people do
not grass
I was especially like to thank our
family liaison officers detective
Constable Louise Wright and Julie Moses
who've worked so hard and professionally
with boundless dedication to achieve
this result
we welcome the sentence given but what I
can say is that my family and I have
already started our life sentence having
to spend the rest of our lives without
Olivia
we are overwhelmed by the outstanding
support of the public during this
horrific time and wish to say thank you
we now ask for time and space to time
process what has happened to us over the
past few months and most importantly
gray Ferrara Olivia who was so cruelly
stolen from us
thank you
[Applause]
together